bonsoir vincent maréchal merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france on
dit la france donc sur un plateau mais
on sent comme l'a dit notre reporter que
la semaine va être crucial etc la
situation pourrait évoluer et pas
forcément dans le bon sens on a déjà des
signes précurseurs iliad est ce qu'on
appelle des signaux faibles la remontée
de décompte des quantités de virus dans
les eaux usées en sont probablement
d'autres indicateurs vous confirmez
bientôt on voit que le nombre de cas
quotidien commence doucement à augmenter
on est dans une situation difficile
d'autant que la période se cette période
hivernale est très très favorable à la
circulation des virus et en particulier
du sart skov 2 donc non il ya un point
de vigilance important à mon sens ce qui
est important c'est d'agir vite donc
c'est un peu le débat qu'on a
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut pas déjà se
fier des indicateurs fiables pour
prendre des mesures qui sont des mesures
efficaces
alors pour vous les mesures efficaces
elle est sur toutes les lèvres nous
penser au rheu confinement ou pas
forcément on n'est pas forcément obligé
d'aller jusque là en tout cas au niveau
national national la mesure efficace
alors j'étais de vous surprendre c'est
déjà de responsabiliser encore une fois
chacun de chacun d'entre nous à
l'exécutif pas être tenu seul garant des
bonnes mesures et des mesures à prendre
qu'il faut vraiment faire attention
continuer à respecter ces gestes
barrière si le virus circule c'est qu'il
y à des niches qui sont favorables à la
circulation du virus c'est qu'il ya des
instants notre vie encore où nous
rencontrons des gens qui qui contamine
parce que nous ne portons pas le masque
donc à une vigilance accrue à avoir et
puis nous payons bas sans doute le
savait recevoir les fêtes de fin d'année
on a pris plaisir à se retrouver mais
sans doute sans respecter totalement ses
règles et les remonter et que l'on voit
aujourd'hui sont probablement un écho
déjà précoce de ces de ses contacts un
peu trop fréquents et on en paie
aujourd'hui
le tribune vous ne citez pas le variant
anglais qui pourtant est bel et bien
déjà sur notre territoire qui serait
deux fois plus contagieux d'un virus qui
l'étaient déjà avant c'est ça le gros
danger
aujourd'hui le danger c'est que ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est principalement
quand même les formes classiques de
korda virus vraisemblablement on est en
train de faire une analyse sur le
territoire on aura une idée plus précise
de la prévalence de ce variant
britannique je vous rappelle qu' aussi
invariants qui vient d'afrique du sud
qui nous pose qui me pose question c'est
pas c'est pas lui qui pose problème mais
si des gens ne sommes pas en mesure de
contrôler correctement la circulation
des virus classique
alors effectivement avec l'arrivée de ce
variant à très fort potentiel de
transmission
on est dans une situation critique il
faut prendre des décisions rapides
aujourd'hui des décisions rapides ça
veut dire quoi concrètement pense aussi
aux écoles qui restent ouvertes ça a été
débattue maintes fois quel est votre
avis sur le sujet alors les écoles les
écoles sont pas forcément les classes
les écoles c'est un lieu où les enfants
parfois se rencontrent sans masque et je
pense notamment aux cantines donc il
serait important de revérifier les
protocoles sanitaires de vérifier que
les enfants ne passent pas trop tembisa
vie sans masque ça c'est ce que je dirai
pour l'instant sur les écoles maintenant
je pense également que concernant le
variant britannique il est important de
mettre en place des mesures d'isolement
isolement doit redevenir la pratique
classique et non pas le test le test est
là pour confirmer des cas douteux ou des
cas présomptif de contamination mais l'
isolement et la barrière qui est la
barrière efficace pour isoler les cas
les cas les plus importants donc on peut
se poser la question savoir si des gens
qui viennent de zones à risque où le
virus circule beaucoup notamment en
grande-bretagne ne devrait pas
bénéficier d'office d'un isolement dans
la tempe d'un test sous quelques
quelques jours qui serait un test
rassurante ou un test de confirmation de
l'isolément vous parlez du variant
sud-africain s'était effectivement une
de mes questions
tous ces variants vincent maréchal est
ce qu'on doit s'en inquiéter notamment
sur l'efficacité des différents vaccins
qui ont déjà été homologué ce qu'ils
vont l'être
alors il est un peu tôt pour le dire des
essais sont en cours
tous les vaccins
qui sont en circulation actuelle vise la
protéine ce pack qui est effectivement
l'une des protéines qui est altéré par
ces mutations
néanmoins les il ya sur la protéine spag
différents sites sur lequel la réponse
immune va s'exercer et on pense
aujourd'hui il faudra le vérifier que
l'altération de quelques sites ne va pas
modifier de façon majeure la réponse
vaccinale toutefois tant que c'est pas
vérifiés en laboratoire
on restera en nous mais globalement les
échanges qu'on a laissé penser que les
vaccins restera efficaces contre ces
formes variantes il faut préciser que
plus vite on bloquera la transmission ça
c'est une des questions qui se posent
encore avec le vaccin plus vite
évidemment on limitera la diffusion et
l'apparition de ces axes de ces deux
scénarios
il ya une bonne nouvelle tout de même
aujourd'hui un nouveau vaccin sur le
marché c'est jodie avec l'arrivée de
modern à 50 mille doses
c'est une nouvelle qui doit être bien
accueilli selon vous mais pas suffisante
on imagine alors c'est une c'est une
bonne nouvelle parce qu on a toujours
cette crainte de la rupture des stocks
c'est une bonne nouvelle également parce
que c'est un vaccin qui circulent à une
température un peu plus élevé que le
vaccin de pfizer ce qui veut dire qu a
priori on aura moins de difficultés de
distribution en revanche les volumes
livrés nous ne sont des volumes
d'appoint on peut le dire aujourd'hui
ils vont nous aider à couvrir cette
première vague de vaccination toutefois
effectivement il faut s'assurer qu'on
puissent vacciner tout le monde et qu'on
puissent vacciner deux fois surtout donc
on attend aussi beaucoup le vaccin
astrazeneca plus simple dans la
logistique
un vaccin qui devrait on l'espère
recevoir un agrément européen bientôt et
qui de qui beaucoup moins cher également
on en parle assez peu du prix des
vaccins c'est pas parce qu'on ne les
paye pas en tant qu'utilisateur
bénéficiaires qui n'ont pas un coup ils
ont un coût ces vaccins et max et
astrazeneca coûte moins cher quand même
alors il faut modérer l'enthousiasmé de
ses vaccins parce qu'évidemment on le
sait on en parle régulièrement sur cette
antenne il y a beaucoup de sceptiques
notamment en france mais aussi cette
déclaration ce soir de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui nous dit que
selon moi il n'y aura pas d'immunité
duo vaccins en tout cas en 2021 quelle
est la réaction du médecin vous être je
sais pas je suis pas je suis pas médecin
je suis scientifique mais je peux avoir
sont quand même dans la alors j'ai pas
vu la déclaration de l'om est sous faire
attention à ce que à ce qu'on dit ce qui
est clair c'est que le déploiement du
vaccin
qu'ils soient justes préventif des
formes les plus graves ou qu'ils
bloquent la transmission du virus
ce déploiement vaccinale va prendre du
temps on le voit il va prendre au moins
six mois en france
certains pays n'ont pas commencé
certains pays n'ont pas encore organiser
la lutte et l'intégration des
calendriers vaccinaux donc je pense que
la remarque de la de l'eau et baisse
tend à dire qu'effectivement à l'échelle
mondiale puisque c'est quand même
l'objectif de l'om est on ne sera pas en
mesure d'assurer une diffusion totale du
vaccin l'échelle mondiale avant la fin
de l'année 2000 21 ans merci beaucoup
vincent maréchal miro log effectivement
professeur de virologie à la sorbonne
universités merci à vous d'avoir été sur
notre antenne